ダンボールってあげた後な意図をもったいないって思いませんぼうか逸話もったいない
と思うんですよ
大事な資源マテリアルですから五箇荘に資源を無駄にしたくないんだよ
今日はこの周りにある段ボールを使って今から
ポケモンの vr がを作ります
ああ
聞こえたぞ今お前達ちょっとこいつ大丈夫か思っただろう
安心しろ俺は小学校のときなんかパパママのエコクールです猫富山県となんかすごい
すごい症になって硬軟片山健頭が俺の束の会ガー幸ネクザれまくった的な感じになって
たんで
芸術点が欠けてると思うんだが
待って作ろうと思います jr かジャージあるがこれな
この数この関税用も作りますまず形だの暖房ロックですねリアルがの形まで持ってい
ます行くとちょっと今日はあんまりず酒今日はで酒ないよ実力主義の世界だから行け
ます
んはぁっ
ああああああ
ええええええ
おっ
んぐっ
car
ん
入った
持っていっ
ああああああ
ん
d っっ
んんーっ
[音楽]
んぐっ
ん
me
はい5はベースはこんな感じなんで今からタッソーをしていきます
ん
ああああああ
んぐっ
me
ん
car
んん
taroo
ああああああ
いっ
tan tan
2日目です
今日で仕上げます
car
入っちゃった
ん
いって言って
none
ああああああ
んん
tame
って
うっ
んぐっ
ん
うううう
んあっ
いっ
par ん坊
ん
uh
ああああああ
tan
うっ
ん
うん機作った
ああああああ
いっ
うううう
んだった
んんん
持っていっ
大丈夫サーバーならたぶんみなさんが思って何までディティールとかまかけないし
ちょっといびつな形なんですけど未だに普段こんなものを作らない人がいきなりこんな
を作るってまあ僕のサイノウちいかあっを今日はいいですね
いやー
末端て来てとうとう期から見たらもうどう見ても出るがで証拠
ずやるでしょ
俺ぜんざいかもしれない第2弾はねもっと派=というのはちょっと徒歩で
第2弾あるかわかん出れば塗っツヴァイんだったんでもう二日間かけて作ったから
ダイヤ使いでしょもうかなりあんまり上手くないです
けど jr だってことはわかるんでまぁ成功だと思ってるんで
おまえらちょっと作ってみ1回ポケモマジでキツイぜ
何度挫折しそうになったか
続けるおかげでできたんですけどね
重機でです
すごいねちょっとパルキアディアルガってたルキア
作る
ちょっとた時はは
きつまたのメグウィンさんあたりがパルキア作ってくれるでしょ
[音楽]
[拍手]
いいした